what's up welcome back to the 46 ever
episode of the iced coffee hour
i'm alex today the podcast has made
fifty two thousand seven hundred and
forty two dollars and eighty four cents
fantastic that was so good that was
incredible mateo this is your calling
now now you got to do the calculations
and figure out how much the podcast is
really making per hour thank you so much
for coming
thank you so much thanks guys for having
me you came all the way to las vegas to
film this
i did i did i really appreciate that
thank you so much yeah
i mean any excuse to come to las vegas
is fine with me so
so we should give a bit of a backstory
this is what i used to do by the way
this was like
a year and a half ago everyone that was
on cnbc millennial money
i would confront them remember this yep
these are the second chances
yeah before the illness i would
basically just invite everyone on if
they're on cnbc i just immediately be
like hey you want to come to la
we'll film an episode together we used
to do that but then
cnbc just started churning out these
episodes it was too much we stopped
doing it
so you're the first person we've had
back on since
i don't know maybe i want to say it's
over a year yeah
really yeah really all right i feel
honored yeah yeah because i think you
have a really interesting story to share
and especially for people want to make
passive income want to
do it just i would say a more unorthodox
career and make a lot of money doing it
how did cnbc reach out to you by the way
they emailed me in october actually when
i was still living in new york city and
i'm the one who got up and moved in the
middle of this on them
so i think i kind of threw them off
because they wanted the new york city
person
and then i became the florida person
like in the middle of it
but they emailed me in october and i was
already in their
database from 2018 when they wrote about
me the first time
and i think they were just you know
looking to do a follow-up to that story
and they reached out to me in october
and it finally came
to fruition in march what did they do
the first time and also
do they only try to get people from new
york
every single episode it's the same exact
thing it's someone in new york it's
another 1200
loft in new york yeah no i know um the
first time it was the title was
how this 25 year old made 150k in six
months that was like the hook
and that was definitely life-changing
for me when that came out
that was when i got my first taste of
all of this and what comes with it
but yeah i think they do only do stuff
with new york people
because they did want me to shoot in my
brooklyn apartment that i left
in december and i still had it through
is it a loft
no oh good okay okay they wanted to
shoot there and i pushed back and i was
like can i just do it
from florida and they they said okay so
i was kind of grateful for that
gosh new york every time
i have no i mean maybe because it's the
dream you know every millennial
i wonder if they do better like i feel
like not anymore after kovitz i feel
like they're gonna have to restructure
that maybe
i think the reason why is because
they're based in new york the person i
was texting jessica i think she had a
917 phone number
okay and that's new york so i'm guessing
it's just maybe it's
logistically it's easier to film where
your office is
so it's like hey whatever's in like a
five mile radius let's just film it
let's get it up there on the channel
yeah
something like that that's probably it
yeah yeah so how did you make
the 150 000 in six months on fiverr
which is what is so shocking to people
um just from writing
10 hours a day writing blogs ebooks
product descriptions all the boring
writing that nobody wants to do for
their business
is the writing that i was doing and i'm
still doing in a capacity i'm obviously
growing the business now but
back in 2018 it was just me doing that
all day every day no days off um
how do you pick up on doing that so
when i graduated college i graduated a
year early so i was 21 i went to work
right away because i wanted to
should have been the first sign that
this was gonna be my destiny
and i received formal training and
writing press releases for
politicians and after i left that job i
moved to new york city for a pr job
and you know everyone knows i quit it
after four weeks and the only formal
training or any background that i had
had was writing press releases
so that was kind of what like piqued my
interest with this because i was like
well i know how to write that at least i
don't know how to do anything else but i
know how to write that
so i started selling that along with
editing and i'm a very like
do-it-yourself person so i'd have these
clients
they'd buy a press release from me and
then they'd say hey can you also write
for my blog or hey can you also
write for my website and i would sit
there and go sure why not
i'll figure this out and and that's
basically where you find me today like
i've
taught myself probably 10 different
types of writing just because people
will pay for it it's been very like a
functional thing
honestly like what is a press release
what does that even know what a press
release is
no every day jack just surprises me with
something new like
it seems like such a general term right
like what is it what is it it's an old
school form of pr but what it is it's
basically this news announcement that
you send out to newspapers
and you're like handing them news that
they can then
spin into their own articles so it's
kind of this like flow
where these journalists need stories and
if you hand deliver it to them you know
you have a better chance so it's mostly
for like businesses and stuff
for businesses you want pr exactly yeah
yeah gosh
i don't know man how much were you
making in the beginning
when i first started doing it seriously
after i had quit my job i made
36k the first year but that was exactly
the salary that i was going to make at a
job that i freaking hated
and that required me to be in an office
for 12 hours so i was happy as could be
with it
why fiverr why not why not do like uber
eats
these deliveries i mean there's a lot of
things you could be doing in that like
side gig market
yeah i mean i blame my mom actually
because when i was working that job in
albany i was bored because
i was not challenged at it and i was
probably texting her one day saying oh
my god i'm so bored how am i
how am i supposed to do this for my
whole life sitting in office i can't
stand any of this
and she texted me back and she was like
hey my friend just told me about this
site you can make five dollars on
and i was like no it sounds kind of
sketchy or like i might like lose my
credit card information on it but
i'm gonna try it out anyway and i signed
up on it not thinking anything of it i
did a flat rate five dollars for
anything
and i was making like 40 a month just a
joke
and you know when i quit my job the
following year
i just had a thought of this is the only
thing that's earning me money right now
so i might as well give it a chance to
show me if it can earn me any more money
and that was it there was no like
oh i love fiverr i love the company
culture you know there was no like
pre-thought it was very like
do or die this site has made me a little
money let's see if it can make me more
and how did you scale that 40 a month up
until like whatever i feel like 30 like
most people don't earn that
on fiverr so how would you earn that
yeah so
they have moved far far away from the
five dollar base they don't even want
you charging that anymore so most people
are charging
50 an hour 100 an hour like every a lot
of people are making pretty good money
on there now and i have a bunch of
people i work with who i'm mentoring who
are making 20k a month now like it's
very possible
i i scaled it by just tiny you know
increment increases to my prices i'd go
from
10 to 15 to 20 to 25 and i'm able to
write quickly that's an important part
of
i think the money i make on there when
people are like this doesn't make sense
and i'm like well i can write
two to three thousand words per hour and
i actually just screen recorded myself
doing it
that i'm gonna post to youtube how fast
is that sounds really really fast i
don't know
is it yeah you know i've had people
weigh in on my social media and tell me
they can do even faster
but i think it definitely is on the fast
end of the spectrum so that i have a
advantage in that way but in the
beginning i was still able to make
100 an hour charging 25 for something
that would take me 15 minutes
so it really wasn't hard for me to scale
it
what would it be what could even take 15
minutes to write something i feel like i
take
it takes like 15 minutes to think of
something no yeah
no and and for me it doesn't because the
writing i do is not actually creative
writing
it's very functional writing like
they'll come to me and tell me exactly
what they want so they'll say
i want to blog on the five reasons cbd
is gonna blow up this
year and i'll literally copy that into
google
and i'll look at who else has written
about this i'll pull up you know no
pre-thought
pull up two articles scan okay okay and
i write it
done i mean it's how do you do i want to
give you as a test
to plan out one of my videos yeah we
could do it just because i spent like
six hours today planning out some
passive income videos six hours
and that's stuff i already knew about
yeah how do you
do it in a way that like it reads well
you have more creative writing though
for your for your videos i don't know i
mean you haven't seen alex's writing
what if what if her writing
is creative you know i'm at a point now
where i'm heading into my seventh year
doing this
and it's like you know the chef that
chops a cucumber every day for two years
they close their eyes and can do it i'm
at that point now where
it's like scary no but mine get longer
now
my planning process used to be like
bullet points just freestyle it but now
when there's so many people watching i
got to be really careful about what i
say
yeah i put more time i put double the
time now than i did two years ago
but you know what that's because that
comes back on you if that script sucks
because they're like oh graham wrote it
whereas i'm ghostwriting for people so i
don't really care
like you know i obviously care that it's
but like the best quality i can do so
i'll get kicked off of fiverr if it's
not
so i want to make sure it's a good
product but my name isn't on it like now
if i write my own article that i'm the
author on that's gonna get blasted out
to the world i'll spend days
combing over it because that will
reflect on me but like
so for the cbd example let's just say
you're pulling from a source that's not
credible but you throw that in there
it's like one of the five reasons like
number four
maybe is not a good reason do they ever
send it back or like what happens if
stuff like that
i mean i've been doing it for so long if
it's something like cbd i do
go pull accredited studies for it so i
would never
um link to a bogus article in that case
because it's
scientific in nature but they have
revisions with each order
so i offer that and if they say i
absolutely hate what you did in the
third paragraph
i used to take it personally now i'm
just a machine with it i go okay what do
you want in it instead
you know let's fix it let's get it done
send it back they go on their way
so that would take you 15 minutes to fix
it no to research the whole thing
yeah because i don't really do a
pre-research process i
i almost read and write as i go like
it's all mixed
into one i feel like i could do an
example for you guys on a laptop while
i'm here and you can
see whatever we should do yeah throw
that in at the end it's like a bonus
clip
yeah you guys got to watch all the way
to the very end to see that i'm
here i want to see the process what if
throw you off just knowing that there's
like cameras like we're watching you
no because i the other day i just did it
because i was getting so much hate on
tick tock for the cnbc video
and they're like you're a liar you can't
do that so i woke up the other day
just like pissed off about it and i
wrote 2000 words in an ebook and i
screen recorded it so you can see the
clock ticking and you can see my you
know my whole process
on my macbook and i haven't had the time
but i'm going to post that to youtube it
took me like 32 minutes
to write it and i'm going to post it and
be like if you people are still gonna
come for me i don't even know what to
tell you
what was it on what did you write about
um the ebook was on
some entrepreneurial topic like 10 ways
to make more money as an entrepreneur
very generic and it was
something i'm familiar with so that that
was you know happened to be it i had
already written a thousand words and i
filmed myself writing 2 000 words on top
of it so basically you think of thought
and then it it's already typed out by
the time you see you're basically
thinking it through while writing at the
same time i'm not even though i'm you
i'm basically
mixing you know for an e-book i'll pull
up 10 different articles and i make sure
they're
they're top sources like it's forbes
entrepreneur maggots inc
it's not some random like dinosaur
rs.com blog you know that is like not
real um i'll pull up what i deem to be
solid sources and i'll take their ideas
you know that's not because i've had
this argument before they're like that's
plagiarism i'm like no no no if you look
up the definition of plagiarism
it's copying and pasting people's words
look at social media that whole the
whole thing would be plagiarism if you
could
get caught for taking ideas from people
so i'll go pull up these articles and if
someone has
a top 10 list of how to be a better
entrepreneur i'll pull up five different
people who have written that and they'll
all have different points
and i'll take a little bit from each one
almost stitch it together so it's
a new um piece of work that
is in no way plagiarized yeah but first
i have to thank our sponsor policy
genius for those of you who are unaware
we recently purchased a new car
and in doing so we had to deal with the
nightmare of shopping for affordable
auto insurance calling multiple
insurance providers was the last thing
we wanted to do and keeping track of all
of the different quotes was an even
bigger headache so instead we decided to
use policy genius
policy genius makes it extremely easy to
get multiple insurance quotes in just a
couple of minutes
all you have to do is head to
policygenius.com and answer a few
questions about yourself and your
situation
then policy genius will compare rates
from some of the top insurance like
all-state or progressive
policy genius will even try to save you
extra money by providing you with quotes
where they bundle your home and auto
insurance
and if you already have insurance you
can use policy genius to reshop your
rates and you could save up to a
thousand and fifty five dollars and the
best part is if policy genius finds a
better rate than what you're paying now
they will switch you over for free
head over to policygenius.com to get
started right now that's
policygenius.com
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice to get it right thank you so
much policy genius and back to the
podcast
and do you just have orders constantly
coming in constantly
yeah do you ever like deny orders if you
have
right yeah uh anything personal like
someone
well every day someone says will you
write my memoir i say absolutely not
absolutely not a memoir for yourself no
their memoir they want me to ghostwrite
for them and i go no
you do you write your own memoir i can
edit it if you want
they want me to basically sit there on
the phone with them for 10 months
and help and listen to their life story
you know that's why they want me to do
it
and i'm like nope how much are they
offered though what if they offer a lot
of money
no no i'm not into customer service
stuff
like i have a short circuit for that you
know i don't accept zoom calls that's
another thing for my orders if someone
can i call you in advance no and if they
say well then i'm not gonna book you
okay and then two days later they always
come back
but i have a questionnaire i'll figure
it out there's no need yeah i mean you
know like emails
like half the time when someone calls
they could have just texted or emailed
that's very true like it's you know like
98 percent of the time they could just
have right
do you use grammarly so i didn't until
this week
oh i did not i just bought it for my
team
well if we can insert a grammarly
sponsor right here if we can schedule
one
smooth thank you for a second i wasn't i
was whipping that up
i was whipping it out yeah oh that was
awesome well done
and uh how many words per minute can you
find the worst follow-up question
no that's that's a good question i
actually really want to know per minute
yeah i don't know i can i mean per hour
i can do up to probably 3 000 words per
hour so
i don't know do the math on that divide
it by 60.
that's incredible that you're thinking
and also typing that quickly
yeah i mean i have to be in silence when
i'm doing it like if someone's playing
music or talking in the background or
something i'm like please shut up
i can't i can't it's full steam focus
wait so is it 3 000 per hour
right yes that's 15 minutes yeah that
sounds about right
50 yeah 15 minutes but also to be
thinking and typing 50 a minute
like that's incredible i don't get that
i don't you know it's like i do get to a
point where i don't know i guess how to
explain all of it it's just like
innate to me so when you're in complete
silence you don't listen to anything no
no music or nothing no and i love music
but i'll end up typing the lyrics
because i get so into music
that um i'm like singing the lyrics in
my head or singing and then i start
typing them
i'll literally like type lyrics or if
someone's talking trying to talk to me
while i'm typing i'll
end up typing what they were talking to
me got it but how do you scale this up
it seems like right now the only way you
can actually
increase your income is by charging a
higher rate because you only have so
many hours in the day
let's go back let's go back to where
you're making like 36k and
we'll build up to that sure sure because
the audience needs to know right right
because we have everyone
wanting to know now how they can make
150 000 in six months
yeah this is controversial stuff right
now if you check my social media
um okay what you're saying go back to
how did i go from 36 to 150 correct
how did you build it up from there yeah
so i just progressively i opened more
services
and i started raising my rates and it
was just that combo that was it
i started to get more savvy with my
sales tactics you know i'd message
people
stupid stuff and be like hey i can do
four blogs for the price of three you
know all the usual sales tactics
that work in a clothing store work with
writing too
and um i started using sales tactics
like that definitely worked i started
messaging
previous clients and saying hey i'll
offer you a discount as a returning
buyer
very simple sales stuff nothing fancy
and you know the biggest
change for me was in 2017 when fiverr
launched
fiverr pro it was called is called
and it's the top one percent of the
platform so
they hand picked me to be part of it
because i had been on there for two
three years at the time they knew me uh
from in new york i had made an effort to
go to their networking events and stuff
you know i know how this game
five or networking event oh they have
events um
i know how the game is played so i you
know i made an effort to go meet them
there
so obviously when fiverr pro came out
someone there must have said oh
you know have alex do it she'll be great
for it and
they reached out to me didn't even tell
me what it was they just said
hey we have a commercial we want you to
be in guy was like 24 and i was like oh
my god
i can't wait i show up to some like
warehouse in brooklyn
and i'm filming it and they're like oh
do you know what this is for i'm like no
no one's told me yet and they're like oh
it's for fiverr pro and i'm still like
i still don't know what that means and
they're like oh it's for the top one
percent of the platform um
this is gonna change your life like
you're you're gonna go from charging 25
to 100 for something you can do in 15
minutes
and i was just like what you know
because i was my brain and that moment
was understanding that i was gonna go
from at the time
that year i think i made 68k to times
four
and i was like what the heck like it was
that was crazy to me uh throughout 2017
they rolled out the beta like they
didn't really get it going
until 2018 like january 2018 and that
was my first month i jumped into the
double digits
uh my earnings on fiverr and um
2018 my income blew up you know went
from 60k something to
like 273k that year and that's when cnbc
wrote about me because they were like
this is nuts
um maybe fiverr hooked that interview up
for me i'm not sure but they did reach
out to me
that's a good advertisement for fiverr
yeah what
oh gosh i just i just thought of this we
should have had fiverr sponsor this
it's not too late it's not too late we
should put the viper sponsorship here if
we could get it
but first let me tell you how to get a
free audiobook from our sponsor
audible as some of you guys may know i'm
actually pretty weak i don't have as
much muscle as i would like to have
wait a minute graham did you write this
i think what jack was going to say is
how could he use audible to listen to
audiobooks like the little black book of
workout motivation by michael matthews
to learn how to stay motivated when it
comes to getting in your workout okay
graham
audible actually gives you one free
credit with your 30 day free trial that
you can use to redeem towards
any book in their entire library so that
means you can be
just like me listening to audiobooks
that help me get off the couch and into
the gym
for free you can use audible to listen
to audiobooks on personal finance
building a business or even how to
improve your cooking skills i'm someone
who wants to stay educated and on top of
things but i don't have enough time to
read a book so i listen to audible when
i am working out
driving or even cooking and the best
part is any book you use your
free premium credit for you get to keep
it forever
visit audible.com iced coffee or text
iced coffee to 500
500 to get your free trial thank you so
much audible and back to the podcast
yeah they've reached out to me so many
times wanting to do a video on fiverr
i've just been like no because i i never
knew how to integrate it with the
channel
i'm like there's never going to be a
natural point where i'm going to talk
about fiverr
yeah sure enough as we're talking about
five i'll reach out
if not then uh then don't go to fiverr
they might say
they have to pay for it this is spicy
but they might push back on you because
they
me and them do not partner up with media
why
yeah you catch me at a funny time in my
fiverr journey what happened
what's going on oh there's there's a lot
to it but
not all that i could talk about but they
me and them we don't partner on media
stuff so they might not sponsor this i'm
sorry to tell you you should ask up work
is it like a controversial thing or is
it
is it drama i don't know what it is
but i i think it's a hunch of mine is
they don't like
the power i wield over them
you know what it is if you do something
bad if you have a controversy
anything then guess what that looks bad
on fire believe it or not
they're working that in contracts now or
i could go online and and tell
the millions of people now who are
coming to me for freelancing help i
could say to them don't use this site
yeah and i don't think they like it's
it's a big thing
it's a big thing now i think the whole
shane the the whole
shane dawson thing really kind of like
started that into motion but now with
david dobrik
and almost every like sort of deal
you're doing now they build it in the
contract that they have right to cancel
if you do something that messes up i
think they're going to be especially
careful
i don't know how that how this is going
to be in the future because now if
companies partner with with creators and
the creator goes and
does something naughty then that's on
the company it makes the company look
really bad
yeah yeah yeah i wonder if fiverr would
ever consider
hiring you for a more like corporate job
for fiverr
like a salaried employee or something
like that what to write your pr
no just just to have you on the board
because you know how to grow
no uh i can tell you no definitely not
no
100 i can tell you no
i mean i'm transparent about it i've
pitched myself to them as an influencer
type so many times and the email just
collects dust
yeah i think it worries them that you're
transitioning to an influencer because
yeah if uh
what whatever you do now is going to be
reflective back onto fiverr
oh yeah 100 percent you're playing it's
safe they're just a business or like hey
listen you want to make money
and you know where you go i get it at
the end of the day i i actually want to
be
still an entrepreneur that doesn't have
someone telling me what to do so it's
like
i might pitch myself but i'm probably
happier not having
someone tell me every day like what i
can and can't post i don't really want
that anyway plus i think it would be bad
on fiverr if they're playing favorites
if they're like hey we're gonna you know
promote alex a whole bunch and kind of
like show her off and like
yeah it wouldn't be it wouldn't be i get
it what would you recommend for people
who see you in
in your position be like i want to make
a ton of money on fiverr
i don't have any skills but i got all
the time in the world what can i do
i have okay so when people come to me
and say that i say to them
okay you might not have skills but you
have interest so you need to start there
what are you interested in because don't
just chase
money that's not going to work here i
picked writing because i've always liked
writing
i was ate writing poetry like it was
always part of me to be a writer
so i would say to them you know this is
your chance to start a new like
do something you actually want to do and
then come back to me like
like i can't just pick it for you so
people really need to spend that time
figuring out first what they want to
offer but you can basically freelance
anything today i would then say to them
start practicing for your friends and
family watch some youtube videos take an
online course everything you need is
online
you don't need to go to school for this
you don't need to do any of it
it's it's all just waiting for you but
you have to decide what you want to do i
can't tell you that
and once they decide what they want to
do how do they even get people to pay
them
there's got to be a secret to like
having a good profile yeah
it's um visuals that is it because
people think on fiverr because it's
anonymous
they can throw up some weird blurry
picture of themselves the sunglasses on
and they're going to get all these
orders
and the same you know principles of
marketing hold true on there
as instagram people want to be able to
trust you and the quicker you can
communicate trustworthiness on these
sites the quicker i see
my students and people have success with
it and there's a lot of scammers on
these freelancing sites people
are um sensitive to it so they don't
want to be scammed there's a lot of
people in other countries who will use
my picture someone else's and pretend to
be
you know unfortunately an american to
sell things so
the quicker you can tell a buyer that
you're not lying and you are
graham and you are jack they will buy
from you and that you can do that with a
bunch of professional
photos of yourself plastered all over
your profile
and these people be like oh i don't want
my image out there i'm self-conscious
about it i just say to them
you're gonna have to get over it soon
because the the digital age is here
and people need to know what you look
like to buy from you
yeah my only experience so far with
fiverr was uh i think a few years ago
i wanted a logo done yeah and so of
course i've had no experience with
fiverr so i think everything is five
dollars
so i see everything from five bucks to
like a few hundred i'm like now i'm
gonna go for the one for five
it was terrible it was so bad
and i i guess you could like you get
what you pay for exactly
i wanted i wanted a hat this is such a
stupid idea you know the
the logo with coexist yeah you know that
you see the bumper stickers
i want to coexist of every single like
currency out there that spelt out
coexist and so i articulated that
message to somebody
who i thought was in the in the us who
said they're in the u.s
but just you could tell from the emails
you know hello sir like just
just the way the dialogue went back they
weren't from the u.s no
uh nothing my my message did not get
conveyed very well
we went through like five revisions yeah
with this thing and i just wasn't happy
with
it and then i just was like listen it's
not like i'd rather just lose
five dollars we're talking about here
yeah so i give them the five dollars i
was not happy with it
but i felt bad do you still have it
i'm sure i do somewhere we you got to
send it to me so so we can put it up all
right i'm sure off i'm sure i'll find it
but the guy because he worked hard on it
it's like i don't blame him for it but
he wanted a five-star review
and so i i felt deep down like i wasn't
happy at all
i want to give him a like one star but
because he asked really nicely i was
like okay
he gets a five star view and i ever
since then i felt so bad
because he had five star reviews and i
bet it's from everyone else like me
just being like i feel bad like you know
five stars you know
right you know it's actually against the
terms of service to ask for a five-star
review so he's lucky he didn't get
booted
yeah um i mean if you pay five dollars
that's what you're gonna get
i use graphic designers on there i have
two that i go to for everything
they charge between like fifty and a
hundred dollars per project they do a
great job at a media kit made this week
it was
excellent but if i booked a five dollar
gig i'm sure it would be
a little suspect lesson learned so what
else does someone need to
look out for let's say if if they want
to run a fiverr business how do you
what what else do you teach all right i
mean i teach so many things
uh let's see what to even through the
beginning because
i think for anyone watching the
importance here is like how they
are able to make money right um all
right if you're just curious but
yeah i mean you sign up you sign up for
free you pretend it's a social media
site i say to people
take your time and fill out the profile
fully i can't tell you like how many
people i get consultations from
and they're like my profile's not
converting can you check it out and i go
get to here and i'm like well there's
typos in the description people now
think
you're in india and that's okay if
you're a website designer or whatever
but not if you're trying to claim you're
an american english
writer now you're lying so you know i
was like well you didn't take the time
to fill your profile that's your first
problem
so that's the first thing i say to
people fill out the profile and take
your time with
it there's it's important that profile
is going to communicate your
trustworthiness
your personality fiverr is very
anonymous so it's kind of like your one
chance to be a human
almost and i don't think people realize
how important that profile is
i then say to them you know you're gonna
open three gigs they're called same
thing
three services and they say well what do
i charge how do i know what to put in
the gig and i go you're gonna go look at
your competitors on there
there's different ranking systems so
you're gonna go find three people who
have the same ranking as you
new level seller you're going to see
what they charge you're going to see
what they word it as and you're going to
you know mimic it and when i say mimic
it i say don't copy it though i'm not
saying copy and paste the title
but take from it you know read over
these titles you're gonna get an idea
of what to write for your own so open
three gigs where you mimic what these
other people are doing
include you know pictures of yourself
everywhere uh you need to have a
portfolio uploaded no one cares where
you went to college or if you went to
college anymore
no one cares anymore they want to see
you know cold hard
proof that you can complete this order
for them and that you're not lying
you're going to give them a trash logo
you know they want to see
that you've done five other great logos
so i and they say to me
well i've never had a paying client i
don't have a portfolio and i'm like well
now you're going to go ask your friends
and family
if they need a logo and you're going to
do it for free for them and i can bet
you someone you know
needs it and you're going to do that a
couple times it's going to be great
practice for you you're going to help
people in your life
and now you have a portfolio so i guess
that's the short answer
so did you notice a jump in business as
soon as you did the cnbc thing
100 um i feel like if anything the first
cnbc go around
uh blew up my social media like i had no
following no one can i mean i had like
a thousand or two but like no one cared
about me or what i was doing
and that first cnbc one put my social
media on the map
um and that was like kind of crazy for
me because i went from
being just like the girl in the corner
at the cafe who writes all the time that
everyone thinks is probably starving
because she's a writer
to you know kind of a thought leader
i don't know i don't love that phrase is
that what people
call that's what they call people who
are like yeah what does that even mean i
don't know but i think of t-h-o-t
like thought like that over there sorry
this is when i say it it makes me laugh
someone needs to make that a t-shirt
like immediately you could make that a
t-shirt i might need to
yeah you could pay someone on fiverr to
design them 100
yeah no i mean cnbc put my social media
on the map which is
when i then wrote my first ebook that i
sold as myself so
i feel like if anything cnbc the first
time didn't really speed up my fiverr
business
but it kick-started my business as alex
fasulo the brand
that was what it did for me and then now
the second go-around of cnbc
has like almost put my whole team out of
standstill with the influx of everything
i was like having eight panic attacks
last week but first i want to thank our
sponsor otis
have you ever wanted to invest in
something you truly believe in and
co-own a piece of culture otis is an
alternative investment app that allows
you to invest in culturally relevant
pieces like collectible cards
art rare sneakers and other items you
won't find on your robinhood account
while i was browsing through their app i
quickly found some interesting items
like pokemon blue from 1998 a psa 10
first edition raichu
and a psa 10 first edition venusaur otis
makes it extremely easy to invest in
things like rare sports cards or pokemon
cards without having to buy the entire
item when a new asset is released it's
split into a set number of shares that
users can invest into
directly in the app and you can use the
otis app to buy or sell shares
24 7 from your online portfolio just
open up the app store
download and install the otis app and
then you're ready to go and with their
weekly drops of new assets the choices
are almost
endless sign up for otis with the link
in the description and get your first
share free when you fund your account
and with that said thank you so much
otis for sponsoring this episode and
back to the podcast
so what was that like filming with cnbc
what was your experience
i'm positive i mean it was nerve-racking
and that i did a two-hour non-stop
recorded q a with them that they cut out
you know their end of it
and um that's nerve-wracking so i'm like
well let's see how that gets pieced
together
you know they could make me sound like i
i suck if they want yep
i felt the same way yeah i was so
nervous because i mean not
not that i said anything i regret saying
but you know they could spin this
however they want 100
and i feel like the only frustrating
thing has been
i went over everything with them like
there's so much more to my businesses
than just that 378k
mark there's so many other businesses i
run like i'm not just
fiverr and people you know are coming at
me where they're like oh you didn't say
you had a team or you didn't say this i
was like no i did it just didn't get
caught into the episode
do you have a team because i did not
give you crap for not having a team you
didn't give me crap you suggested it
okay
you didn't give me crap no some some
people have come to my thing and they're
like
good to see you following graham's
advice and i was like oh
wow i'm like okay thank you you sit down
i'm like i already thought of it we got
such a great army though i have to say
you are very loyal followers i've
noticed thank you so much that's a cue
to hit the like button
yeah if you're if you're a dedicated uh
subscriber
hit the like button yeah see how many
dedicated subscribers there really are
they love you everyone who hits the like
button is a dedicated subscriber
and hits the notification bell and gets
your free stock down below in the
description
excellent see i gotta be more like this
i don't know how to do that that's
perfect
wow okay so so you filmed all day with
cnbc
the episode post did you know i was
gonna react to it
to be honest i didn't even know who you
were yet
i'm so sorry i've since then i've
stalked the crap out of you
and was fangirling coming here because i
i admire you and everything you've done
so
um i started reading the comments like
you probably shouldn't do
on the video when it first came out
because i was like okay is this going to
be a negative or positive response from
people i was nervous
i've gotten a lot of both my whole
journey with this i have a lot of hate i
have a lot of
love i have both and i was seeing really
positive comments i was like oh my god
that's great and then people started
saying
can't wait till graham sees this wait
till graham sees this graham's gonna rip
her to shreds
and they were painting it like i was
thinking you were gonna be
horrible the way they were writing it i
was like who
i was like oh my gosh this graham guy's
gonna come and kill me like who is this
grand person
just wait until graham sees this and i
looked you up
and i was like graham oh my god i know
okay
i looked you up and i was like okay this
guy isn't mean he's
he's fair like he just does like a
breakdown of things because people are
like
he's gonna rip her to shreds where
people were like ripper to shreds graham
no because you used to man you've gone
soft yeah you've gone soft on millennial
money reactions yeah definitely i hope
not
there was that family in uh in hawaii
and i was reading the comments on them
and they were like graham is gonna just
rip this family apart
i don't feel like i would i don't know
really no yeah yeah i was like
i was scared of you okay and so many
people commented it that i was like
okay i think graham is gonna do a
reaction to this because because
i saw thousands of people comment your
name so then when your reaction came up
i think i was even more nervous to watch
that than i was the cnbc video
because i was like oh my gosh is this
guy going to destroy me
in this because because cnbc cut up my
finances in a way that made me seem uh
naive with managing my finances and i'm
not gonna sit here and say i'm an expert
because i'm not
and would love you know any feedback of
course but i was like
oh god like is this guy gonna just like
crucify me
and i sat down you know to watch yours
and then i went through and i was like
oh my god that was so nice like i i was
like surprised at how nice it was i i
felt like you could have ripped into me
a little more
maybe we should go harder that's the
thing because i think the early
episodes were doing more views but i
think that's because it was new
and millennial money was given out like
really good content
yeah you kind of like watch the videos
and you kind of just like review them
now
instead of going in like with the
mentality of like
you know there's nothing there's nothing
for me to really dig in there's always
something
not really not no they have gone softer
have you watched all the millennial
moneys
i well them are his reactions them
i've watched like six of them in the
beginning
they used to provide examples of people
that would be spending money
so frivolously yeah and now it's just
gone like every single person is like
literally a saint
like you would think that they like came
from heaven how good they are yeah
just like as a person and with finance
yes they they pick the
ideal people who do no wrong who save
orphans from burning buildings who adopt
animals and puppies and like save the
world
uh back when i first started watching
these episodes that got me into them
uh to begin with was alex pardo he was
spending like a few thousand dollars a
month on cars
uh very little money in savings was
keeping his money in a checking account
all designer clothing gucci that was a
great episode and then the one after
that was
a guy who his dad lent him 20 grand he
lost it all in the stock market
and then he bought a motorcycle totaled
it
um and came out with his own business
like i loved that okay
so yeah i mean i don't know maybe
they're worried about
being i feel like in today's culture
they have to be careful with
like scrutinizing people because they
might get yelled at if they come after
someone no
i wonder it could be that or also
someone who would do that i don't know
if they could take the scrutiny
because people probably tore those guys
to shreds including you
where like they see your video like
cause this get any worse and then they
see graham stefan comes out with
my theory i'll tell you my theory on
this i think
cnbc does not like me reacting to their
videos
i see it as a symbiotic relationship
like i'll react to the videos they give
me the content it's good for everybody
right but i think and i've always felt
like they might think i'm kind of like
making a mockery
of of their work so i think they're
purposely going and trying to
find like angels together on the channel
knowing
that like i'm not gonna tear apart an
angel
like there's no way you know just
whoever they feature on there is doing
like the best work in the world
i i can't say anything negative about
that
yeah i mean i i guess when i think back
to like the interview that they did with
me they didn't really ask me any
hard you know they didn't really go
looking for any
uh dirt or drama which certainly exists
in some of my story uh they didn't go
looking for it
which made it an easier interview for me
but i was still panicked that they would
cut it up and make me sound terrible
yeah yeah so i think the two things for
you
what what did i what did i dig into with
you what the food
you it was it the food but food
and then the cash in the cash for the
jeep let's talk about your mom for a
second what happened there
um what do you mean like
bring people up to date who don't know
the situation all right so
my mom actually used to live in florida
years ago because she loves florida
did not like living in new york was
super happy in florida
i want to stay here because i keep
thinking i'm in florida and i'm not
right now um
she moved back to albany new york to
take care of my grandma
she was dying basically and after my
grandma passed
um my mom was gonna sell the house you
know was kind of
gonna make good money from that and it
was getting to a point where
just with the winner coming she hated
the winner and everything and my grandma
had passed and we were like mom why
don't you just move back to florida now
you don't need to be here
okay you you're not happy here the
weather sucks
i gotta i can't dig too hard into like
where i'm from but it's just it's rough
you know and
and she i was like i have an idea i have
you know regrettably a lot of money
sitting around it has since been put in
places okay
it's in places um i was like let me
you know let me front it and then you're
gonna sell this house you just pay me
back
why don't we just jump you know let's
get this moving you can show the house
easier without being in the house my mom
always has like 18 animals which is
always
like a problem for showing homes so i
was like get the parrots get the cats
get the horse you know
a horse there's a horse and there's a
horse here
and uh head to florida like get out of
here and um she was like all right yeah
that's fine are you sure you know
whatever and we're like yeah
and my family you know i work closely
with my mom actually run a business with
her i work with my sister we're very
close with business stuff
so we we kind of share money anyway like
we're kind of old school like that i
guess
and um that was it wasn't really that
big of a story to it
she sold the house two months later
right away um paid me back
that was it yeah that was a lot easier
of a situation than i thought yeah i
thought you were buying your mom a house
your mom said she'd pay you back but
they made it a little more confusing i
think yeah
yeah it was it was nothing too exciting
got it yeah
where is your money in places yeah you
said high interest savings account is a
a bank it's um it's all over the place
i'm gonna throw my best friend under the
bus who's the cpa who's gonna
come work for me next month because i am
not good with
numbers and all that i am the creative
who wakes up and
writes all day and comes up with 10 000
ways to bring in money but then when it
comes to managing it i'm not good
so right now um i just bought a house
not all in cash i took out a mortgage
okay uh that's where some of it is i
two weeks ago bought my first crypto
bought some ethereum a little bitcoin
for everyone who's telling me that oh
there we go there we go
looking into nfts because i like to make
art um i'm actually you're creating an
app
selling them yeah because i'm taking
screenshots of the crazy things people
are commenting on my social media right
now
and i was like maybe this would be a
funny nft because people are writing
like crazy stuff
we're in a bubble man yeah yeah you know
what there's a meme that i saw on reddit
of uh it's a whole bunch of cars driving
in one direction it was like people
selling nfts and one car
driving in the other direction people
buying nfts
yeah the the types of the honest truth
within
this a week or two yeah no very few
people in our are buying
nfc unless it's like a people or like
jack dorsey or like an elon musk
i'm sure it'll disappear you know who
knows yeah i mean who knows
another place i have it in is drop
shipping business i do with my cousin
he's managing and scaling it very
quickly which is awesome and then i'm
testing out my cousin came up with this
uh caleb boxes youtube automation
accounts you can buy you heard of that
no what is this so
you pay like 20k and
you basically are paying a youtube team
to create a news channel for you like
i'm not you would never know i own this
youtube channel basically
okay and they put out content every week
and the idea is you're investing in a
channel that's going to eventually make
you
residual income from you know growing in
the youtube everything
what explain this i'm just in the
beginning with this
what is it can you can you back out or
the money's already transferred no i
already paid for
for the year so what is it explain this
so what happens do you pay 20
20 grand a year is that how much you
paid 20 000. i split it with my cousin
because he came
i got to give him credit he he found
this he found this so
uh they put out a video a week so we own
a celebrity news channel and their team
can you tell us the channel
i don't even know the name of it that's
how bad i've been
we could find out and bleep it out if
you or we could give you a freebie i can
just text my cousin if you want he can
tell me yeah
any idea like how the logistics go with
with investing in this youtube channel
or was it your cousin
that just said hey i need ten thousand
dollars to invest in a channel like why
did you send me the money
yeah he did oh it's called celebrity
101. that's the name of the channel okay
so let's let's see
if you decide later you want to bleep it
out we could bleep it out or
it's free promotion so it's called
celebrity
celebrity 101 yeah that's it
so like this video is what one million
dollars could buy you around the world
this doesn't cost twenty thousand
dollars to do this at all
i mean maybe he just needs to like have
enough money for food and stuff so he
can
sustain himself while he's making
pumping out content but then you lose
the drive to really do a good job at
this you know it could be terrible but i
would say
one year from now let's see what was the
the website caleb box
that guy caleb is that a youtuber yeah
caleb maddox
caleb the kid the kid that i'm roasting
on youtube
you should watch the coffee watch the
coffee still
yeah there's no way just my opinion here
but like i'm looking at the channel
i'm not a fan of the channel so each
week when they put an episode out they
ask
us to give feedback so it's in a it's in
a stage now where we're working with
their team still to get it
right if if this is really that
lucrative i'll tell you caleb doesn't
need money
is there any chance that you can get a
refund before the the one-year period is
vested or whatever
yeah i think if the the channel has gone
nowhere in one year
yeah you you have enough say in social
media to basically go and say
hey i want a refund not happy with this
this is not what i expected
other things came up so sorry and if he
says
no first of all you have the platform to
then say you want a bad experience what
if she just doesn't want to do that
because
i don't want to do that yeah yeah it's i
have enough drama with my brand already
that i'm like right i think it's fine
test it out for you because what if it's
testing it out
what if it takes off right i'm surprised
though when when you said you were
investing your money that you
i didn't hear stocks why not why not
index funds or why not
volunteer i just honestly like my
my day is so lopsided right now because
i'm in a situation where
my business is it's a good problem
they're blowing up
so fast that i don't even have time
literally like to shower okay i shower
like a shower
but that's you guys know like that's
that's where i am right now like i am
not even eating meals because i
am trying to just put out the fire of my
exploding everything
that this is all stuff i want to do like
and i plan to this year but that's why
i'm trying to make
my best friend who's a cpa she promises
me she's going to come work for me in a
month because this is the stuff i'm just
going to have her do for me because she
knows all this stuff
okay i'll tell you it's it's really
simple you don't even need her
as as a cpa maybe as an accountant
maybe but i'm telling you the all you
would need to do
i wouldn't actually do any other
business like the youtube business
not even worth your time even if you
have someone else managing it not worth
it
ethereum i can honestly go either way on
that um
just vt sax that's it vtsax
all you have to do is just link your
bank account to vanguard
and then just set an automatic
investment every month or every week
that's it that's your only investment
that you're going to have to make for
the next 20 years
that's it that's a simple simple is that
it's really as simple as that then sure
that's it that's what i need it to be as
simple as i have no time
that's literally all you need and to set
that up it's probably going to take you
15 minutes
and most of that is just like typing out
your information so you could probably
do that in
three minutes sure so that's it but that
would be your only investment
vanguard is or you know what fidelity
they have a completely
free fund it's called fizzrocks
f-z-r-o-x
and we'll put it up on the screen all
you need to do make make the account
with fidelity
okay uh they're i was there they're more
free than vanguard so there's like a nom
i think it's like a dollar every ten
thousand dollars is a fee or whatever
but there's this this is free that's all
you need to do all right you guys let me
convince you yeah and it's very simple
it's very easy and all i would do for
you is to set it up
where like every month i don't know five
thousand dollars gets invested
automatically
you don't even need to think about it
and just don't even check the account
yeah i mean i wouldn't be yeah yeah yeah
that's it so you don't need
any anybody else doing this for you just
you could set it up yourself
save the money okay you guys have me
convinced good i honestly think though
at considering what you've got going on
right now i think a better investment
honestly than
just buying index funds would be hiring
like an assistant or something
yes that well okay so i have a couple
virtual assistants but i need a personal
assistant and that's
my best friend who i keep talking about
that's what i'm trying to hire her to do
because i'm in dire need of one yeah and
at this point
i'm like why would i hire some random
person i don't know when this person who
i trust
having access to everything could just
come do that for me
i agree i'm hanging in there for her
yeah no i agree with
what jack said how else are you scaling
this up how many people do you have now
i haven't cnbc cut out from that that
you're like oh cnbc i mentioned that
they i mean they cut out a lot about
everything that i'm doing you know like
that i'm working with other people that
i'm working on growing my business that
i have
um an online course business that's
blowing up you know like they they cut
out
mention that yeah well everyone hates
the online course stuff like they
you know that gets people all riled up
but
um they they just they cut out the
details of everything and just you know
they hit you with the big
shock title and then they don't explain
everything below it
so yeah i mean i work with other writers
right now i have for the last two years
um i didn't work with writers for the
first four years
so i always say that in my literature
and everything
when people are like oh you didn't scale
the six figures alone it's a lie and i'm
like no i did you know like i i did i'm
now working
with other writers because i want to
scale to seven figures that's the goal
here
so like anyone listening like you can
scale to six figures as a freelancer
completely by yourself
if you want to scale to seven figures as
a freelancer you need you need help
um you can't just do all those orders by
yourself anymore
and this year my goal is to um
veer off of fiverr you know it's been
great the 20
they takes getting real old uh year
after year they've made
hundreds of thousands of dollars off of
me uh it's getting to a point where i
have the brand now where i'm like why am
i
why am i taking this hit and so i'm
working on developing the business off
of fiverr at the same time right now is
managing
the 35 orders that are coming in every
day because of cnbc that i don't want to
turn down
but i'm starting to form partnerships
with pr companies that's the end game
here
you get the pr company to outsource 100
articles to you per week
you get three four writers to do that
you buy grammarly boom
that's how you hit the seven figures uh
not on a five or low i don't think you
could hit a seven figures on a fiver i
mean maybe you could i mean i
would never say never is that what
you're aiming for this year
it's seven um yeah
yes yeah to say i did it you know i
don't know i'm always like
chat like playing games in my head with
myself i'm like if i did this i want to
see if i can do this i'm sure you guys
are the same way yeah
if i hit three million on youtube i want
to hit four i want to hit five
you know you're always looking to the
next thing yeah you think you could do
it
what's holding you back no i i think i
can maybe do it this year
and actually because of cnbc so are you
saying seven figures just from my
freelance writing business or just in
general
in general i i think in general i
actually may be able to this year
because of cnbc and because of my online
course sales
yes wow so thank you cnbc
the irs is always watching i know people
always write that too like
i'm like you guys i you can look at my
tax return it's all there
don't worry has entered the chat oh i'm
sure
don't worry everyone says that same
thing they're like show us the returns i
was like yeah let me give you my social
security card while we're at it
you know what's so funny i had a guy a
long time ago ask me oh he didn't
believe my youtube income and this was
like two years ago too
uh didn't believe it and just went off
on me in the comments section
and i said send me a dm on instagram and
i'll prove it to you
and so he sent me a dm on instagram and
i'm like hey i'm going to send you a
screenshot
right now with like the time and
everything on it so you're going to know
like i don't even have time to photoshop
this
here's a screenshot of this immediate is
photoshopped
that's not real yeah so what i did is i
had someone else take a picture of me
holding up you went this far i went this
way yes it was like two years ago i was
at the gym
and it's like i think i do i i do the
same thing because it bothers me so
that one bothered me for something
because he really just like was angry
this guy was
and what did he say once you sent that
picture that's but
oh oh so i set the picture of me like
holding it up to show him like i don't
have to like there's no way this
photoshop
yeah but then youtube takes their cut
i'm like that's
after youtube's cut like that's what i
take home
i need to see a tax return though
there's there's no way
to see a tax return what makes him think
he's entitled to
that information and then i just then i
just blew him off after that and then
and then of course
as soon as i'm like you know blow him
off yeah i didn't think so
yeah exactly i think he was probably
just doing that to provoke you honestly
like there's no way that he actually
could be i don't know yeah someone today
said that exactly to me
they're like because i jokingly i need
to stop doing this like hit back at some
random person a couple days ago
and i just said yeah let me mail you my
tax returns while i'm at it cause they
were saying i lie
they literally wrote today 18 comments
because they're obsessed
that she wrote so where's that tax
return like she was dead serious
like she actually thought i was gonna
post it like truly
you weren't i i'm like i'm like what
where's the taxes yeah yeah did you not
bring it today
no i forgot yeah my bad
when we talked i think you on instagram
were like i'm down to do the the
cat memoir really right yeah i did i
wrote back
i wrote back because i i saw the video
and somebody gave me the advice they
said
comment on the video he reads the
comments he'll see that you commented so
i commented that
i would write the book maybe that was it
yeah yeah i was like
yeah i'll write about ramsay wait so why
would you do a memoir for ramsay
so i wouldn't really call it a memoir
it's more so like a day in the life of
an
insta pet how about we call it cat tails
and yeah it's cat tails but the cover
is ramsay like with his tail or so like
a cute cartoonish picture of like ramsay
chasing his tail
that's genius yeah people use it as like
marketing materials so it's like if you
were trying to book ramsay as like a
a cat food cover or whatever
you would do a chapter uh if you wanted
to be really dorky i like write as
ramsey and like the first person
and you would like talk about the for
like 2 000 words how the cat would be
such a good sponsor you know it's like
you're almost like selling the animal in
the
book yeah i mean i would leave it to you
to make it however you would want
how does how does it work how would you
how would you write because you would
you would have to listen to me talking
about ramsay to be able to pick up like
what he likes and what he doesn't like
so it's tough with the pet thing because
when it veers into super personal
information that's when i sometimes then
decline it because i don't like to do
the things where i would have to get a
two-hour recording from you
i would i more so always ask people to
provide me with the topics that they
want covered and then let me take it
from there so
if you're like i don't care what goes in
this book but i want you to touch on
it that i got ramsay from a shelter i
don't know where you know or
i want you to touch on that i want you
to touch on how he's available for
sponsorships on instagram and
i want you to touch on how his his
favorite thing to do is go for a walk
and then i just kind of would take it
from there and then i i would say to you
um is there an insta pet book out there
that you like
you know i could check it out and kind
of emulate it for you that's what i
would usually
what was the price i think we talked a
thousand dollars together i do 10k words
per thousand only
that's kind of a lot though for a pet i
would actually steer you towards the 5k
word ebook uh 10 000 words would be a
lot for a pet
there's not a lot to write no honestly i
want to sell it
you could sell the 5000 money that's all
so whatever i pay i want to sell it and
make the money back
um i sell all my ebooks i sell online
are about seven to eight k
and i make money off of them so you can
i i would steer you towards like six
seven k for this 10k would be a little
too much
would that be covered that's a great
question i mean i can tell you the pages
it depends how fast you read
um cover to cover if you want this to be
like an eight hour sort of like
[Music]
yeah one to two hours that's uh so like
in an afternoon like hour and a half in
the car
is what that is um and i don't have it
in me to write
more than that about a pet basically
okay
i hit a point all right um i'll pay you
would it's paypal or venmo whatever you
want okay i'll pay you
uh is it a thousand for ten thousand or
so if it's
less words it's fewer words it's less
less money yes
okay we could we could leave it just
open
and however many words it is we'll divvy
it up based on
yeah you know what i would actually tell
you the word count based on what info
you give me because if you gave me
nothing i'd be like graham you got to
help me out here i can only do like 5k
words with this
i i need something i need a recording or
something
i feel like it's going to be a long book
because everything from like
you know his life on the streets he was
a he was a stray okay
so we could i don't know like at least
20 minutes about like
life on the streets and what that's like
like grown up in uh you know west adams
with what's that like
uh then finding finding each other
and just like like him snuggling up and
then him
he still is on kitten cat food because
he does not like any other cat food so
maybe like something about that
okay um all first person from the cat
though you want right right so i would
talk about
his kitty anxiety yes okay yeah talk
about that
uh he does not like car rides and he
just meows for like two hours
straight that's true um what else
he's not extremely sociable like he's
getting there he's a little skittish
how old is he two years oh he's a baby
yeah so he's really friendly once he's
once he sniffs you and he likes feet so
my cat does too it's like a thing right
so if you take off your shoes
they like sniff and roll on it just
sniffs everything and sometimes they'll
just you know go back so maybe talk
about it talk about that
i don't know i could talk uh i could
talk forever about this i won't i won't
bore you we gotta save some for the book
yeah for the book
some surprises inside
[Applause]
[Music]
so basically what alex just did was we
tested her skills
and we gave her how long was that like
12 minutes probably
probably 12 minutes ish to write up
the her top five picks of 2021
in stocks so wait so you don't want me
to read it you can but i i didn't
write it with the idea of it being read
so it might sound funny but you can
still okay you get what i'm saying um
yeah
let's see the top five stocks of 2021
let's let's see which one we picked okay
so it's making me nervous
okay as more people than ever as more
people than ever before stay home and
amidst the pandemic they're looking for
ways to make passive income while
supporting their families it's safe to
say that 2021 has become the year of the
side hustle while people share their
insight
for far and wide on social media related
to their personal income channels
although these side hustles are
abounding
in sorry sometimes it's hard for me to
read our abounding and lucrative
potential
the original side hustle of the stock
market remains to this day one of the
best ways to make money at home
as a pandemic-proof solution to earning
money in your sleep the stock market
deserves to be on everyone's 2021 side
hustle's list
no questions therefore you're probably
asking yourself what stock should i
uh should i be buying to make the most
money this year
here is our here's our list for the top
five stocks to buy in 2021
overall that was incredible it's good
that was so good
but you see it's it's um cumbersome to
say out loud because
it's for writing you know you get it i
write when i write out my script i
i write it as though i would be saying
it and then i go through and i say the
entire thing beforehand
because sometimes it just doesn't flow
let's see what do we got we got alb
oh so and none of this was copy pasted
so if you look at the bottom of the
document no none of it's no
no none of it's copy and pasted um i
listed the three reference links that's
what i always put for the client to see
and i opened three different articles
and i took
one or two stocks from each article so i
stitched it all together so i didn't
just mimic
you know i didn't just rely on one
article okay so we got alb
electric vehicles could potentially
account for up to one-third of auto
sales in the next five years
um then next we got neo from neo
uh if you've been asking us in early
2020 we would have said
neo was not going to survive the year
the company itself cost
uh cast substantial doubt on its ability
to foray into the future
okay uh but after posing posting
delivery numbers and earnings
that spoke for themselves the stock
managed to soar from two dollars and
fifty cents to forty seven dollars and
thirty cents
used to be not anymore the dark horse of
2021 that we recommend you to follow
i bought neo uh then we got adobe adobe
brand speaks for itself
okay then we got spotify all right and
then we got fiverr i had to do it
then we got fiverr okay uh and we'll
wrap up with saying
these certainly are not the only stocks
we recommend that you watch in 2021 but
based on our research we expect big
things from all five on the list which
is why uh
which is why if you have some spare
change laying around invest in one of
these stocks above
immediately that's a bold
immediately yeah
it's funny because you just never see
yeah like like if graham were to say
something like that you would be ousted
because that's like the one forbidden
thing like you never say like guys
why we highly recommend you look into
these uh
as potential candidates for like you
always have to say something like that
like right yeah so then that's where the
client would send back a revision since
i'm not a stock expert like they are
they would send it back and they'd say
oh that's incorrect and then i would
just change that line
i just invest in one of these stocks
about immediately it's not funny
and then write a not financial advice
and then i like this
have any stock investment questions our
team is here to help contact us today
with references
yeah so the end of every blog is
supposed to be a call to action that's
why they purchased it so i use the word
immediately because you're
you're almost trying to scare them into
buying your help that's the idea you
want to scare them
got it i i listen i have to say over
it's it's
impressive for 12 minutes yeah if you
told me you spent all day on this i'd be
like
it's not that for 12 minutes it's
impressive
yeah i mean and i was also a little
nervous doing that right now
yeah that wasn't my like i was like oh
god people are gonna read this
um there it is for you know the haters
who say that that's impossible
and how much do you would you charge for
something like that so i charge 100
for a 500 word blog however i was
nervous
and i rushed that so normally i would
have probably spent
another 5 10 minutes on slowing it down
and i wouldn't have been all jittery
writing it
but i do charge a hundred dollars for it
yeah no
and um i offer seo so if they you know
provide me with their keywords i'll make
sure they're in the title and the text
i don't i don't offer advanced seo but i
make sure there's no keyword stuffing
going on i make sure it flows naturally
in the copy for them
that's a pretty good value cool thank
you so much for coming on
it was really great meeting you you're a
fantastic writer
and an efficient speaker thank you jack
thanks guys for having me and for giving
me an excuse to fly to las vegas
you're welcome we're uh we're sad you
didn't gamble but uh then
i have three more days here it's not too
late i was gonna go do that immediately
after this
immediately yeah that word again we
recommend you go and gamble immediately
with any spare change that you have
exactly
jeez okay well with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it as always
go and subscribe add us on instagram the
information is down below in the
description
make sure to smash the like button get
your free stock down below
and uh what else do we need i think that
i think we're good that's it thanks for
watching
until next time
46 ever episode of the iced coffee hour
my name is alex
so far the podcast is made blank okay